annulation d
bonsoir le monde entier a soudain pris
conscience de la gravité de la situation
jusqu'à présent les chefs d'état joué à
se faire peur et les opinions publiques
ne croyait pas vraiment à la guerre en
quelques heures hier
tout a basculé l'échec des discussions
entre américains et irakiens genève a
semble-t-il traumatisé les dirigeants y
compris ceux qui étaient qui restent
déterminés par exemple george bush
sa première réaction l'illustrent il
semblait surtout atterré un solde des
nazis
de wever one thing au ghana et le chef
de la maison blanche n'est pas le seul à
éprouver ce sentiment la plupart des
dirigeants sont maintenant persuadés que
saddam hussein veux faire la guerre
il faut croire que le chef de l'état
irakien pense ce qu'il dit les
américains at il déclaré nageront dans
leur sens c'est cette obstination qui
incite perez de cuellar mais aussi la
france à prendre d'autres initiatives et
ses dernières initiatives seront prises
en totale concertation les ministres des
affaires étrangères des douze
rencontreront en effet demain à genève
perez de cuellar
le secrétaire général des nations unies
qui sera sans doute le dernier émissaire
de la paix à bagdad alors qu'elles sont
encore les cartes de la diplomatie
pascal verre d'eau la longue course des
diplomates
d'abord il ya ceux qui jouent leur
va-tout par conviction personnelle
l'horreur de la guerre pour conjurer le
sort et l'échec d'une première tentative
de médiation cet été avec les irakiens
l'infatigable perez de cuellar le
secrétaire général de l'onu qui pourrait
proposer l'envoi d'une force neutre au
koweït sera bagdad samedi sur le fil du
rasoir
douze résolutions des nations unies qui
le cadenassent et la méfiance de saddam
hussein qui affirme que l'onu est
manipulé par les américains ensuite il
ya les européens désabusés à l'image de
jacques pose le président en exercice de
la communauté européenne
le dialogue n'est pas possible at il
lâché ce matin malgré cela au nom de la
raison mais aussi par volonté politique
d'exister et d'avoir une politique
étrangère commune
les douze qui ont essuyé de nombreuses
rebuffade vont relancer leurs
initiatives pour rencontrer l'irakien
tarek aziz mais pas question d'aller à
canossa
c'est à dire à bagdad enfin solidaire de
l'europe mais traditionnellement tournée
vers le maghreb la france ou plutôt le
forcing français pour que l'irak fasse
un geste et marche d'exploration
symbolisée par le déjeuner des
ambassadeurs arabes et de roland dumas
pour la petite histoire à la même table
représente
du koweit et celui de l'irak mais
officiellement pas d'initiative franco
algérienne destinée à élaborer un
compromis pour le ministre algérien des
affaires étrangères reçu tout à l'heure
au quai d'orsay
les consultations se poursuivent
qu'avant traduction la paix dans le
golfe
de plus en plus improbable on le perçoit
bien le monde arabe lui même divisé très
perturbé à l'idée de s'entre déchirer et
certains pays arabes pour cette raison
s'active beaucoup à bruxelles ce matin
les ambassadeurs et représentants des
pays arabes se sont réunis il croit
encore à une solution diplomatique et
veulent utiliser ces cinq jours au mieux
reportage de notre rédaction européenne
françois poule et mathis il m'a plutôt
confiant à bruxelles pour la vingtaine
d'ambassadeurs arabe auprès de la
communauté
ils s'étaient réunis cet après midi à
l'initiative du gouvernement belge
les éléments d'un compromis existe et
l'europe doit jouer son rôle
voilà en substance le message adressé il
ya des nouvelles de décembre
qui inspire quelques optimisme non
content et cela touche au pénal
il ya beaucoup de parties avant qu'ils
atteignent les tâches dont le président
est en pleine phase qui pourrait avoir
eu alger alger ou non dans la peau
européenne tant commis l'irréparable des
spas lie toutes les chances de pouvoir
l'éviter c'est est-ce que vous pensez
que l'algérie peut organiser dans les
jours qui viennent une initiative en
liaison avec la communauté et les pays
européens
l'algérie a déployé et continue de
déployer tous les efforts que pourrait
contribuer à des inventions
au moins il y à une initiative concrète
celle qui consiste à éplucher de
secrétaire général des nations unies à
bagdad dont quelques parties sont
affirmés et les portes ne sont pas
fermées pour les autres initiatives
tournées aux yeux sont braqués sur
l'algérie actuellement sur le secrétaire
général des nations-unies perez depuis
la nervosité chez les diplomates
fébrilité chez les militaires sur place
dans le golfe les armées semblent se
mobiliser quelques jours en effet les
militaires se préparent avec une
intensité redoublé sur toute la ligne de
front d'après les experts militaires
occidentaux
la guerre dure est de 3 à 30 jours un
conflit éclair pour lequel plusieurs
scénarios ont été étudiés quelles sont
ces scénarios réponse avec hervé dino
alors ou dans le désert les armes
crépitent pour une ultime répétition
trois scénarii semble se dégager
deux d'entre eux s'appuient sur une
configuration de conflits qui se
limiterait à une confrontation entre
l'irak et l'ensemble des forces de la
coalition internationale
le troisième prend en compte une
éventuelle implication d'israël pour le
contre premier cas de figure une guerre
éclair d'une semaine au maximum les
aviations américaines et alliées mais
n'aurait des opérations massives sur
tous les points stratégiques irakien les
aéroports les sites industriels de
bassorah les voies de communication et
les forces stationnées sur la frontière
et la cote comme étienne la supériorité
américaine écrasante en volume de force
en puissance de feu et en logistique
entre et crédible ce scénario
deuxième cas de figure malgré des pertes
importantes
l'irak résiste à ce premier assaut les
blindés serait alors engagée
mais il semble que l'état major
américain veuille éviter à tout prix une
guerre frontale trop coûteuse en vies
humaines
avec l'appui de l'aviation les
américains entre et d'enveloppés l'armée
irakienne en attaquant à l'ouest avec
les chars tandis qu'à l'est les marines
débarquerez aquatique
troisième scénario israël est partie
prenante dans le conflit une entrée en
guerre spontanée de l'état hébreu semble
exclu george bush ayant fait savoir à
ses alliés qu'ils devaient s'abstenir
d'intervenir mais si israël est attaqué
hilary postera et cela pourrait
entraîner un éclatement de la coalition
anti saddam qui transformerait cette
guerre en un conflit israélo-arabe qui
ne manquerait pas tant flammes et
l'ensemble du moyen-orient est
précisément notre invité ce soir et
monsieur ovadia sofer l'ambassadeur de
l'état d'israël en france bonsoir
transports croyez vous à la guerre
monsieur stauffer
c'est toujours une possibilité
connaissant des loin sada pour singe
serait originaire de bagdad
je crois que psychologiquement il a
besoin d'un affrontement une
confrontation maintenant ils
affrontaient les dires ans maintenant
elle et la france demandent tout entier
donc vous pensez qu'il ira jusqu'au bout
et ça elle ne pointe pas la guerre nous
voulons une règlement pacifique un
règlement politique mais pas à n'importe
quel prix
non mais vous dites que vous connaissez
bien lire à vous est né en irak
en effet vous avez quitté l'irak à quel
âge 15 ans et vous connaissez donc de
près le peuple irakien est ce qu'ils les
prix asus adam hussein dans cette guerre
qui peut être une horreur faut dire que
le peuple irakien a été martyrisée par
la dictature de saddam hussein qui était
cinglante g vivent dans mes mémoires
comment mon cousin a été pendu dans le
square de bagdad
en 69 donc le peuple il n'y a pas un
opinion publique qui peut limiter
l'action de saddam poussins actuellement
je vous propose monsieur souffert
d'écouter une réponse de monsieur tarek
aziz à la question d'un journaliste
hier soir à genève écoutons et nous ce
que vous pensez qu'il va le faire
je crois que saddam hussein ferons
tourner à tout prix israël à un conflit
qui ne le concerne pas alors si l'irak
attaque israël que fera israël israël se
défend et dieu merci nous n'avons jamais
demandé à quiconque de nous défendre
vous n'avez pas le sentiment que vous
risquez de tomber dans un piège qu'il
vous tendra si israël répond d'une
manière militaire à l'irad aussitôt
l'egypte et la syrie qui sont dans la
coalition anti racket retireront ils ont
quasiment dit il soit elle
ça va un acte de légitime défense israël
avait été réparé la voix de son premier
ministre
israël ne provoque pas le conflit nous
ne sommes pas pour le conflit ne sont
pas concernés nous voulons rester être à
l'écart de ce conflit mais si saddam
hussein aux attaques et légitime que
nous nous défendre il ya des propos
pessimistes qu on nous rapporte d'israël
et missiles irakiens pourraient
atteindre des villes israéliennes
en effet il a des missiles nous mais
nous sommes confiants dans notre
capacité d'infliger à saddam hussein une
coup très dur et c'est pour cela que à
mon avis la dissuasion d'israël israël à
une action dissuasive qui peut-être
faire réfléchir ce soit dans le conseil
avant de s'attaquer à issor n'êtes vous
pas tenté d'attaquer les premiers ce qui
vous portera tort non nous ne nous ne
faisons pas un attaque prévente là c'est
sûr ça c'est sûr mais on n'avait pas le
sentiment que de quoi qu'il arrive vous
serez impliqué dans un conflit
nous espérons de ne pas être impliqué
parce que ce n'est pas de notre intérêt
nous ne voulons pas être impliqués
mais évidemment vous avez entendu les
menaces de saddam hussein d'ailleurs il
ya quatre mois même avant la crise et
nous a menacé de brûler la moitié
d'israël avec ses armes chimiques
bactériologiques et peut-être demain
atomique
merci monsieur se faire si la guerre
éclate le 16 janvier plus de 16 mille
militaires français participeront aux
opérations combat certains d'entre eux
sont déjà déployés sur le sol saoudien
une infrastructure médicale française a
été mise en place à quelques kilomètres
du front les hôpitaux de campagne qui
sont partis hier en container de rennes
vers le golfe
reportage de notre station arènes eric
piolle est conçue sous forme de modules
cet hôpital mobile est déployable en
moins d'une heure il présente aussi deux
autres avantages essentiels une grande
mobilité car il est transportable en
conteneurs isotherme par voie terrestre
ou aérienne
et une totale autonomie grâce à un
groupe électrogène le module de
servitude fournit l'énergie électrique
la climatisation l'alimentation en eau
air comprimé oxygène pendant 24 heures
sans interruption
le module de chirurgie est semblable à
celui d'une clinique un bloc opératoire
un équipement radio et divers appareils
d'assistance qui permettent toutes
sortes d'interventions en arabie
saoudite
il sera servi par le personnel médical
de l'hôpital ambroise paré de rennes un
autre module de réanimation est prévu
pour accueillir quatre blessés comme
dans la salle de chirurgie l'équipe
médicale pilote différentes fonctions
température et hygrométrie avec un
système de commande relié à un
calculateur inconfort d'exploitation qui
a encore été améliorée pour faire face
aux vents du désert
on a dû intégrer des filtres
supplémentaires et une ventilation
complémentaires est-ce qu'il a fallu
former du personnel spécialement pour
son utilisation
oui on a formé des personnels du service
de santé des armées
pour l'exploitation là et la maintenance
du matériel sur site
six autres modules sont en réserve à
rennes le programme commenté par le
service des armées porte sur la
construction de 200 modules médicaux en
dix ans malheureusement il ne faut pas
hésiter à le dire la guerre si elle
éclate risque d'avoir des conséquences
dans notre propre pays comme aux
etats-unis ou en grande-bretagne et on
pense bien sûr aux attentats et pour
faire face aux menaces terroristes le
premier ministre a déclenché depuis le 2
janvier le plan vigipirate un plan
confidentiel défense qui comporte
plusieurs phases mais déjà certaines
mesures sont appliquées visible
notamment la surveillance accrue des
points sensibles sur tout le territoire
béatrice pouvoir sensibiliser prévenir
riposté c'est un plan en trois phases
tout d'abord accroître la vigilance de
tous les fonctionnaires en faction
devant les points sensibles ministères
ambassades aéroports grands magasins
centres edf ptt sur tout le territoire
équipé policiers gendarmes de gilet
pare-balles c'est la phase prévention
tout comme l'armée qui renforce ses
gardes et ses patrouilles pour ses sites
et installations
depuis quatre mois la surveillance des
frontières terrestres maritimes et
aériennes s'est accru mais on reste dans
un schéma dit classique de lutte
antiterroriste même si les milieux
concernés se sont réunis 30 fois depuis
le mois d'octobre la menace qui pèse sur
la liberté sur la démocratie à partir du
moment où des forces politiques
on déjà dans le passé parfois ont
récemment annoncé des envisager de faire
appel au terrorisme cette menace est
évidemment croissante lorsque la crise
s'accroît c'est la raison pour laquelle
les mesures de précaution sont également
croissante selon un schéma est un plan
de montée en puissance qui sera
proportionnel à l'évolution de la menace
si la coordination européenne fonctionne
la moindre information été changés tous
les services de police et les autres
travaillent comme dans la période la
plus noire celle de 1986 il faut pouvoir
faire face à des attentats aveugles ou
ciblées troisième point donc la phase
riposte de l'interpellation à l'état
d'urgence dans une période aussi
sensible
on envisage le pire pour ne pas être
surpris du coup toute la classe
politique française a oublié ses
querelles habituelles pour ne plus
penser qu'au golf et l eau qu elle aura
l'occasion de s'exprimer au parlement
françois mitterrand l'a annoncé hier en
cas d'échec des négociations il
convoquera le parlement en session
extraordinaire mais il n'y aura pas de
déclaration de guerre
comment vont fonctionner les
institutions françaises en cas de
conflit explications de charles sanviti
dans quelques secondes
apparemment peut-être un petit preuve
mercredi 16 janvier au koweit les
irakiens sont toujours là l'ultimatum
vient d'expirer comme prévu en france
françois mitterrand convoque le
parlement et le 17 la session
extraordinaire s'ouvre la procédure
sénateurs et députés ils sont habitués
déjà fin août ils s'étaient réunis pour
entendre le message du président une
lecture sans vote
mais cette fois changement de décor les
parlementaires ont écouté et puis votée
en tout cas pas sur une déclaration de
guerre à l'irak
françois mitterrand est formel
le problème n'étant pas celui d'une
déclaration de guerre la france 2
déclare la guerre à personne étant celui
de savoir si les représentants du peuple
entendent comme le fait le gouvernement
que la france applique les résolutions
des nations unies
donc exécute le mandat dont il est
chargé comme ceux qui ont voté la
résolution alors le 17 janvier le
parlement votera très certainement c'est
sur une déclaration de politique
générale qu'il devra se prononcer la
suite d'une déclaration de politique
générale je pense que c'est ce qui va se
passer
le gouvernement pourrait très bien
laisser les parlementaires reprend guy
parlementaire qui seraient nos positions
avec lui prendre l'initiative d'une
motion de censure mais je pense que dans
une situation comme celle-là il est
préférable que le gouvernement pose la
question de confiance en ce qui concerne
le message que le président de l'apli
pourrait adresser au parlement ce
message serait lui aux parlementaires
mais il ne peut pas donner lieu à débat
il n'y aurait pas de vote
issu de la lecture de ce message et
blessures répétées bref le 17 janvier le
feu vert du parlement sera important
pour l'exécutif mais pas forcément
décisif précisément les hommes
politiques français seront ils diviser
ou accepteront-ils l'union sacré il est
encore trop tôt pour le dire les
réactions recueillies aujourd'hui par
michel le maire reste encore prudente
d'ign ont certes mais pas de véritable
divergence du rpr ou parti socialiste
devant la gravité de la situation
l'heure est plutôt au consensus jusqu'au
16 janvier au matin je crois que
personne ne peut ni ne doit se résoudre
à la guerre et que tous les efforts qui
peuvent être faits pour tenter lab une
issue diplomatique permettant le
maintien de la paix doivent l'être
l'opposition sur ce sujet est
particulièrement responsable nous ne
faisons pas de querelles subalternes
nous restons tout à fait dans
l'opposition mais là il s'agit du pays
il s'agit de la guerre peut-être et donc
nous devons être extrêmement attentif à
ne pas déchirer le tissu national
face à une droite parlementaire qui se
veut responsable pierre mauroy ne peut
accepter qu'au sein même du ps
des fausses notes trouvent les esprits
et s'il y avait un conflit
je suis en droit d'exiger de tous les
socialistes le rassemblement la
mobilisation derrière le président de la
république et même s'ils sont d'un avis
divers noms de ne rien faire qui puisse
entraver l'action de la france
parti communiste france plus à sos
racisme ou les verts il existe aussi en
france
un front anti gay ne se réuniront tous
samedi pour une manifestation à paris à
l'appel des 75 75 personnalités de tous
horizons politiques et confessionnelles
qui appelle purement et simplement en
retrait de toutes les troupes de la
région du golfe
un appel réitéré aujourd'hui au café du
corps du croissant reportage de
véronique d'aurel et philippe guinet
dans les mémoires pacifiste le café du
croissant est un puissant symbole jean
jaurès relisez son ultime appel à la
paix quand il y fut abattu le 31 juillet
1914 et il n'était pas encore enterré
que ce n'est déjà le tocsin de la guerre
les signataires de l'appel des 75
veulent croire que l'histoire n'est pas
voué à la répétition que la force du
droit
lorsqu'il est violée ce n'est pas
fatalement la force des armes
il faut plus que jamais négocié et la
france 1 peut avoir un rôle et des
responsabilités considérables pour
prendre des initiatives d'ici le 15 le
jour du 15 et dans les jours qui suivent
pour que soit construite la négociation
comme mode de règlement il n'y a pas de
fatalité de la guerre il est encore
temps de se mobiliser pour dire non à la
guerre
je crois beaucoup au poids considérable
de l'opinion publique
l'opinion publique est plus forte que le
plus puissant gouvernements du monde
jeudi que l'on a commis une mauvaise
action en essayant entraîner le peuple
français dans cette guerre en disant
qu'on l'avait pour le droit ou pour
l'honneur car il n'y a pas plusieurs
lectures du droit nous ne sommes pas
morts
heureusement pour d'autres france
gression du droit qui se sont produites
les territoires occupés d'israël le
liban et le conseil de sécurité a
condamné directement dans les mêmes
termes
alors il n'y a pas une opportunité de
faire la guerre pour le droit est
transgressée
voici pour les arguments quant au moyen
de cette guerre à la guerre
ils sont d'abord ce que sont les
personnalités qu'ils recrutent on
insiste beaucoup chez les 75 sur leurs
diversités d'opinion les moyens
dépendront ensuite du nombre de ceux que
l'appel mobilisera test samedi avec les
manifestations prévues dans toute la
france et à paris je vous le disais au
début du journal il y a dans le pays
comme dans d'autres pays une véritable
prise de conscience de la gravité de la
situation et sondages le révèle il n'a
paru intéressant d'entendre ceux qui
n'ont jamais connu la guerre
vous allez voir dans cette classe de 4e
au collège diderot de besançon certains
adolescents sont inquiets et même très
grave reportage de catherine rock et
thierry chapuis parce qu'il est complet
ainsi d'éviter la guerre
sert à rien ne peut pas toujours tout
réglé par la guerre sert à faire
pourquoi on salit pour faire la guerre
ou de s'allier pour faire la paix nous
n'avons pas envie de perdre les gens qui
soutiennent beaucoup le progrès en
général c'est pour faire virer est là
c'est pour détruire des millions
d'innocents on a déjà vu ce que tu as
fait à hiroshima alors je peux à peine
de recommencer avons écouté la formation
vu à la télé à genève n'ont pas été
tellement d'accord je pense qu'il y aura
la guerre quand on voit les militaires
débarquent et armés jusqu'aux dents
c'est pas pour rien on a par trop fait
peur aux gens moi je pense au contraire
qu'on parle on ne parlera jamais à titre
de la guerre parce que ont les fesses ou
là il ya eu beaucoup de morts pendant
les deux premiers les deux guerres
mondiales
il y en aura peut-être si vous cessez
d'éclat on vous n'en parlera jamais
assez il faut qu'on soit bien conscient
de la gravité de la situation et même si
on a peur je pense que l'américaine elle
date beaucoup tremblé je sais pas
comment ils peuvent dépenser par jour en
allant arabie saoudite
et puis il y en a quand même pas eu un
bon repas de noël
regardons maintenant les conséquences
économiques de la tension depuis
l'annnonce de l'échec de la négociation
de genève plusieurs places boursières
ont chuté toutes les valeurs refuges
sont en hausse pas de mouvement de
panique pourtant à la bourse de paris
aujourd'hui le marché a été très calme
les investisseurs attendent apparemment
la date fatidique du 15 janvier avant de
prendre des décisions
reportage de marie-hélène tichoux et de
mes poupart yal'espoir la boue ce monde
aujourd'hui la déception de la bourse
baisse
mais pas d'affolement palais brogniart
le volume des transactions est faible
mot d'ordre il est urgent d'attendre
on tue le temps et on s'amuse n'a rien
d'une interview
évitez est tellement anesthésié que ils
ont besoin de s'amuser dans les bureaux
des agents de change même calme plat de
fête les marchés boursiers ont déjà
anticipé la guerre les bourses sont
toutes très inactive là il ya eu comme n
ad part importante clientèle de l'ordre
de 3 millions en france de l'ordre de 10
millions aux etats-unis c'est-à-dire
près d'un tiers de la caddel en général
c'était des petits porteurs qui avait
obtenu en france des types de
dénationalisation quelques titres ça ne
représente pas du tout une vraie
diminution du portefeuille sang froid
ce mot d'ordre défini l'ambiance à la
bourse de paris jusque quand pour les
professionnels en cas de guerre les
courbes et seront mais ne chuteront pas
dans tous les cas des mécanismes de
sauvegarde sont prévues
concrètement les cotations seraient
suspendues si la baisse est trop forte
pour les boursiers le plus dur est
d'attendre
voilà c'était le dernier volet de ce
dossier que nous avons voulu complet sur
la crise du golfe
huguette résume les autres événements du
jour la lituanie sous la menace d'une
administration présidentielle directe
dans un message lu par un porte parole
mary gorbatchev n'exclut pas de prendre
cette mesure autoritaire
si l'état balte continue à ne pas
respecter les lois soviétique réaction
de vito tu as lens vers 10 le président
iranien
l'appel de gorbatchev et d'un ultimatum
la radio appelle la population à se
rassembler devant le parlement
sans doute un règlement de compte les
trois hommes exécutés hier soir en face
d'un bar à avignon était bien connu des
services de police les trois malfrats
avaient déjà été impliqué dans des
affaires liées à la drogue et à la
prostitution
les agresseurs ne leur ont laissé aucune
chance l'ancien bras droit de jacques
médecin jean oltra sous le coup d'un
mandat d'arrêt provoqué hier par la
police jean prat ne s'est pas présenté
au rendez vous dans une lettre il a
indiqué qu'il devait s'absenter pour
quelques jours
le procureur de nice a ouvert une
information judiciaire pour abus de
confiance
série de nominations antenne 2 le
nouveau directeur général se nomme eric
giuily âgé de 38 ans il était le
directeur général des chargeurs
communication et de pathé cinéma
il succède ainsi à jean michel gaillard
deux autres nouveaux venus
jean pierre dussault à gauche directeur
des programmes et bibiane godfroid à
droite adjoint chargé de la
programmation avec ou sans accent
circonflexe les académiciens français
réunis cet après midi ne sont pas
parvenus à prononcer la trêve dans la
guerre de l'orthographe
ils se sont séparés sans procéder à un
vote les immortels se réuniront de
nouveau jeudi prochain fin de ce 19 20
marques hautement vous donnera d'autres
informations à 22h20 du cinéma ce soir
sur la 3 avec deux films deux policiers
le premier à 20h40 les hommes avec
michel constantin et à 22h40 la cible
hurlantes un film britannique et le
temps dans quelques instants avec
florence klein bonsoir adema 19 heures
bonsoir
on
m
bonsoir fin de la tempête qui a touché
le nord-ouest du pays la nuit dernière
et ce matin les rafales ont dépassé 100
kilomètres à l'heure sur les côtes de la
manche et on a relevé 95 km alors à
orléans et sur la région parisienne
demain ce sera enfin l'accalmie sur ces
régions l'anticyclone reprend des forces
et la perturbation s'atténue en
descendant vers le sud nous avons
également battu des records de douceur à
strasbourg où il a fait 17 degrés 4
colmar 19 degrés mulhouse 18° 6 et 20
degrés à clermont ferrand il n'avait pas
fait aussi doux depuis 1923
d'autre part il faisait 15 degrés ce
matin à paris vers 6h demain la
perturbation s'étendra du poitou
charentes au nord du massif central
jusqu'à la lorraine
elle donnera un peu de pluie sur l'est
et quelques gouttes seulement vers
l'ouest
une amélioration s'installera sur le
nord avec eux du soleil de la bretagne
au nord il y aura tout de même des
averses sur les côtes près de la
méditerranée le vent de sud-ouest
provoquera des entrées maritimes et donc
de la grisaille sur le reste de la
moitié sud
des nuages et des éclaircies ainsi que
du soleil en corse avec le retour du
beau temps et bien nous verrons aussi le
retour de la fraîcheur les températures
minimales boeuf ou de 4 à 5 degrés sur
le nord ouest
ailleurs elles seront stationnaires il
fera donc 4 à 6 degrés sur le nord ouest
et 6 à 9 degrés sur le reste du pays
dans l'après midi les températures
baisseront pratiquement partout sauf sur
le sud-ouest où le temps ne changera pas
beaucoup par rapport à aujourd'hui
au cours des prochains jours la baisse
des températures va s'accentuer samedi
elles seront conformes aux moyennes
saisonnières mais attention lundi retour
des gelées il fera jusqu'à -7 degrés
dans l'intérieur
sinon ce sera donc l'accalmie sur la
moitié nord avec le retour d'un temps
anticyclonique
alors que la grisaille descendra vers le
sud samedi soleil sur le nord-ouest de
grisaille sur le nord-est et puis sur la
moitié sud
dimanche soleil sur la moitié nord et
ciel couvert sur le sud lundi beau temps
partout mistral et tramontane se
lèveront demain n'oubliez pas de citer
la saint paulin très bonne soirée se
réfère 3